this morning a reno man convicted of  torturing and killing dogs went before  the state parole board jason brown was  sentenced back in 2015. he was  mistakenly identified as a violent  offender before his for his crimes but  those crimes only apply to human victims  dogs are considered personal property in  nevada so that makes his crime in the  eyes of the law non-violent and makes  him eligible for parole much sooner this  morning brown addressed the board  i have earned every day i've spent  prison and prison is where i needed to  be over these years  i admit that my crime was cool and  disgusting and it shows me how mentally  sick i was at the time of my arrest  parole commissioners usually take  several weeks to make an ultimate  decision